dites simplement bonjour pour snapchat super et donc
combien de personnes ici ont déjà échoué
leur téléphone vibrant dans votre poche l'ont
choisi et il n'y avait en fait
rien, levez la main d'accord, regardez simplement
autour de vous et réalisez qu'environ neuf
personnes sur dix ici
vivent réellement quelque chose appelé  des
vibrations fantômes qui sont un peu folles quand
on y pense bien, car cela
signifie que vous avez été tellement conditionné par
votre smartphone que vous imaginez maintenant des
choses qui n'existent pas, nous avons en
fait un mot pour cela, cela
s'appelle une hallucination, alors ce que je
J'aimerais parler aujourd'hui de la manière dont nous pouvons
réellement utiliser l'intelligence artificielle pour
nous débarrasser de tout ce bruit et de toute cette
complexité et de cette oppression que la technologie
apporte aujourd'hui, car avouons-le si
nous avons déjà un problème aujourd'hui avec
quelques appareils à chaque essai  pour imaginer
ce qui va se passer dans dix ans quand
nous aurons des centaines de milliards d'
appareils connectés autour de nous la quantité
de complexité que nous allons devoir
gérer  s un humain va augmenter de
manière exponentielle heureusement vous savez qu'il
y a quelque chose que nous pouvons faire à ce sujet
et c'est très simplement utilisé l'
intelligence artificielle pourquoi parce que si un humain
seul ne peut pas gérer autant de complexité
alors pourquoi ne pas créer un assistant à
qui vous pourriez déléguer tout de  ces
choses un assistant que nous connaissons tellement de
choses sur votre vie qu'il pourrait
répondre à toutes vos questions faire tout
ce que vous voulez qu'il fasse et même
gérer directement tous vos appareils afin que vous
n'ayez même plus à toucher la technologie
lorsque vous regardez  à ce qui se
passe avec l'intelligence artificielle,
cela prend un peu de temps pour
commencer, mais aujourd'hui, nous assistons en fait à
cette croissance exponentielle ultra-rapide et si
quelqu'un ici a déjà senti récemment que
quelque chose de terrifié se passait ou que tous
ces champions de l'IA battent aux jeux,
ce n'est en fait rien  à voir avec de nouveaux
algorithmes, cela a principalement à voir avec
des effets composés de manière exponentielle, nous
avons d'énormes quantités de données accessibles  e
pour la première fois pour apprendre à ces
machines à faire des choses et à
avoir une puissance de calcul infinie et les
deux ensemble, vous savez essentiellement
s'entraider et c'est donc là que vous avez
la croissance super rapide, ce que cela signifie, c'est
que d'ici 2025, nous pouvons probablement nous attendre à la
les capacités de ces assistants IA
dépassent de loin toute complexité qu'ils
devront gérer en raison de la technologie
et ce que cela signifie, c'est que votre
perception de la technologie dans la
vie quotidienne va disparaître dans
les arrière-plans, tout comme l'électricité
avant que tous ces appareils connectés ne le fassent
commencez à devenir complètement intelligent pour l'
intégrer dans votre vie à un point
où vous n'en aurez
plus conscience c'est
quelque chose dont les gens parlent
depuis les années 80 ça s'appelle ça parce que l'
informatique est ce concept vraiment incroyable
que vous pourriez en quelque sorte  avoir une hyper
connectivité que tout autour de vous
est un appareil connecté tout est
activé par la technologie mais d'une manière ou d'une autre  vous vous sentez
toujours débranché,
cela semble réel et c'est vraiment
important parce que si vous considérez
qu'aujourd'hui déjà nous commençons à être
manipulés par nos smartphones,
c'est en fait la différence entre être
un esclave ou être un humain, alors
qu'est-ce que nous voulons dire  par l'
intelligence artificielle et en particulier comment pouvez-
vous construire un assistant qui
comprend vraiment votre vie, donc je vais
vous montrer un peu des choses sur lesquelles nous
avons travaillé, tout ici est de vraies
données et c'est en fait assez
intensif le premier  ce que vous voulez
savoir, c'est où sont les gens, pourquoi parce que l'
endroit où vous vous trouvez est très fortement corrélé
au type de choses que vous faites et
si vous voulez que votre assistant puisse
comprendre votre vie et bien vous aider,
il doit savoir tout ce que vous
En d'autres termes, vous
devez suivre chacun de vos mouvements tout au long de la
journée, mais l'emplacement est très bruyant, de sorte que votre
smartphone ne sait pas vraiment
où vous vous trouvez.  les points verts
sont l'endroit où votre téléphone vous voit, donc même
lorsque vous êtes à la maison et que vous ne bougez pas,
votre smartphone ne sait pas vraiment
où vous êtes en fait,
tous ces endroits pourraient être des endroits
où vous êtes en ce moment  alors maintenant, ce qu'elle
veut, c'est fournir encore plus de données à votre
aide afin qu'ils puissent
commencer à différencier ces
endroits et à déterminer exactement où vous
êtes, vous voulez regarder des choses comme des
endroits où vous avez été dans le passé
qui sont très populaires les différents
fois que vous pourriez rentrer chez vous et ce que
cela vous dit en ce moment, c'est que vous êtes
actuellement dans une résidence dont vous ne savez toujours pas
si vous êtes chez vous ou que vous savez chez votre
ami à proximité s'avère dans ce
cas précis ce qui était vraiment
intéressant était de regarder les e-mails de
cette personne parce qu'il faisait référence à l'
un de ces endroits et invitations
qu'il envoyait à d'autres personnes et
donc vous savez que cela doit être
significatif, vous ne parlez pas au hasard
d'endroits que vous n'envoyez pas  invitation
aux gens à aller aimer la
maison de quelqu'un d'autre afin que vous voyiez comment, en combinant ces
différents éléments, vous pouvez commencer à
obtenir de plus en plus d'intelligence et de
plus en plus de compréhension sur la vie de quelqu'un
ensuite, vous voulez être en mesure de
déterminer où les gens ne sont plus réellement
au même endroit mais en déménageant
ailleurs donc ici vous savez que vous
voulez savoir si vous prenez le métro si
vous faites du vélo si vous marchez du vélo
parce que ces habitudes sont aussi quelque chose
que vous devez prendre en compte si
vous aimez  prendre une voiture pour aller au travail vous
voulez que votre assistant
prépare automatiquement ce trajet pour vous si vous
aimez prendre un taxi vous voulez que votre
assistant réserve automatiquement le taxi
lorsque vous sortez de chez vous la prochaine fois que vous
irez au bureau en fait non  ensuite, vous entrez
dans le métro, ce qui est très courant pour
tout le monde ici à Paris, mais vous
savez que vous ne pouvez pas vraiment suivre les gens
sous terre parce que vous n'avez aucun
signal, il s'avère que vous pouvez sti  Je le ferai en
utilisant le baromètre du téléphone pour que
le baromètre mesure la pression de
votre entourage et il s'avère que
lorsqu'un train accélère dans un tunnel
cela crée un effet physique qui
crée un pic et une variance de pression et
donc en regardant l'heure  entre ces
pics, vous êtes en mesure de mesurer très
précisément la station que vous
traverserez sans avoir à utiliser le
GPS réel et des choses comme ça, ce qui est assez
étonnant là où vous y pensez, mais je
veux aussi que vous pensiez à quelque chose la
prochaine fois  quelqu'un vous demande d'accéder au
baromètre de votre téléphone, il pourrait en
fait vous demander de donner accès à
votre position et c'est quelque chose d'
assez étonnant avec les données en général, c'est
que vous pouvez les transformer et faire des choses
avec qui n'ont pas été conçues pour dans le
en commençant ensuite vous allez au bureau même
problème vous ne savez pas où vous êtes en
ce moment vous voulez regarder un
calendrier et des choses comme ça mais ensuite
vous allez rencontrer un
pour un café tu  rns dans ce
cas spécifique, il s'agissait d'un message texte qui vous a vraiment
aidé à comprendre ce qui se
passait, vous devez donc également être capable de
comprendre le langage humain et le
langage naturel pour extraire les lieux et les événements dont
on parle, c'est essentiellement un moyen
très simple de  en le regardant, vous
pouvez imaginer cela comme une sorte de chronologie
des activités que vous avez faites dans le
contexte dans lequel ces choses se sont produites,
ce qui est une façon très simple de
représenter l'information, mais c'est aussi une
façon très mécanique de regarder votre
vie  à droite, il y a une
séquence de données très bien structurée car il
s'avère que le cerveau humain ne
stocke pas vraiment d'informations de cette façon, vous
savez que vous n'avez pas de base de données comme vous
auriez une feuille de calcul Excel à la place,
ce que vous avez est un tas de différents
des informations éparpillées un peu
partout et vous créez des liens
entre ces concepts en fonction de la façon dont ils sont
liés les uns aux autres et ainsi par exemple
si je vous dis de venir chez moi
demain de
cette façon vous récupérez cette information
c'est que d'abord ou pensez à moi
car je suis juste devant vous et
ensuite de moi vous naviguez vers le
concept de ma maison puis pour
confirmer le concept de ma maison à l'
adresse  de ma maison et c'est un moyen très
très efficace de représenter les
connaissances et les informations est quelque chose
qui s'appelle en fait un graphe de connaissances,
donc la première chose que vous voulez faire lorsque
vous voulez construire un
assistant intelligent est de reproduire cette
structure dans les assistants  cerveau donc
vous voulez représenter toutes ces
informations que vous collectez en les agrégeant
dans ce graphe de connaissances c'est génial
si vous cherchez à comprendre les
choses mais cela n'aide pas vraiment à faire les
choses parce que l'information elle-même n'est pas
exploitable ce que vous voulez c'est commencer
brancher ces informations dans
des applications et des appareils de fournisseurs de services très spécifiques
, par exemple si vous avez une
réunion, vous voulez savoir que vous savez que
vous pouvez les rechercher dans Google  Cartes, vous
devriez avoir un restaurant, vous voulez le
rechercher, une table ouverte, une petite conversation, peu
importe si vous allez au bureau, vous
voulez pouvoir réserver directement un
uber pour aller à votre bureau et c'est donc
une chose que nous avons
Nous avons travaillé récemment sur la création de
la première couche de cet assistant qui
lui permettrait d'accéder très simplement à
toutes les données de votre
vie et à partir de là, de vous proposer directement
de lancer des applications sur votre smartphone afin
que vous ne  vous n'avez même pas besoin de
vous rappeler ce que vous pouvez faire où se trouvent les données
quelles applications vous pouvez
utiliser c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
compliqué mais également nécessaire pour
l'avenir du mobile car la
complexité de la gestion d'autant d'applications sur
votre smartphone est juste  impossible aujourd'hui,
donc cela m'amène à l'une des choses les plus
importantes que je pense que les gens
ne comprennent pas à propos de l'
intelligence artificielle, le but de ces
assistants est de tout savoir sur
votre vie si vous  vous avez regardé l'exemple
avant de savoir où vit cette personne,
vous savez ce que cette personne sait, vous savez
tout sur cette personne, vous avez
accès à chacun de ses e-mails ou de
ses SMS et donc la question
de la confidentialité est un problème énorme qui
n'a pas '  Cela n'a pas été abordé jusqu'à présent, pensez-
y une seconde, imaginez si vous aviez
une personne physique réelle, les assistants Yoshi,
il vous aide à faire des choses dans votre
travail quotidien, imaginez si cette personne,
chaque e-mail que vous lui envoyez, lui envoie
tout ce que vous lui demandez.
l'enverrait à une autre entreprise, que
penseriez-vous de votre
assistant personnel qui donnerait à une grande entreprise l'
accès à chaque élément de données auquel vous lui
faites confiance, cela ne sonnerait pas bien,
alors pourquoi accepteriez-vous réellement cela
d'une assistance artificielle qui a
encore plus d'accès à vos données, cela n'a pas de
sens, c'est pourquoi une
chose très importante ici est un concept de
confidentialité dès la conception que vous devez créer en tant
qu'assistant pour gérer votre da  ta d'une manière
qui garantit que personne ne peut y accéder et que
personne ne peut le voir mais vous c'est votre vie
ce sont vos données si quelqu'un vous dit
sinon vous faites probablement
quelque chose de super louche en arrière-plan
alors ne leur faites pas confiance tout ce que je vous ai montré
jusqu'à présent  nous pouvons le faire fonctionner directement
sur votre smartphone c'est extrêmement
compliqué je ne veux pas entrer dans les
détails mais c'est faisable
cela signifie que rien ne doit se passer dans
le cloud en tant qu'entreprise je n'ai jamais besoin de
voir vos données  et je peux toujours fournir un
assistant qui est beaucoup plus intelligent
que tout ce que vous pourriez trouver
aujourd'hui, alors la prochaine fois que vous utiliserez un
assistant, pensez simplement à cela, c'est aussi un
cristal de confiance que nous avons remarqué chez les
personnes faisant une étude qu'ils ont en fait
veulent vous donner accès à leurs données
quand ils savent que votre ex
fait quelque chose de bien avec c'est
quelque chose dont la plupart des gens rêveraient
mais ce n'est pas possible parce qu'ils n'ont pas l'
angle de la confidentialité maintenant quelle est la prochaine chose
vous voulez pouvoir faire c'est une bonne
chose d'avoir toutes ces données centralisées
quelque part mais vous savez que le genre de
but d'un assistant est que vous pouvez
lui demander de faire quelque chose de bien, vous pouvez
lui demander de réserver un uber pour aller à un
adresse donc c'est assez simple
à comprendre pour une machine vous savez que vous pouvez
comprendre que la réservation est l'action
uber est un fournisseur 18 Houston marque est
le boom de l'adresse fait c'est à cent
pour cent sur vous savez analyser la
syntaxe de la phrase parce que la
phrase  est autonome
il n'y a rien d'ambigu dans la
phrase chaque élément d'information sur l'
accès est contenu dans la phrase
elle-même mais il s'avère que la plupart du temps
vous ne savez pas vraiment exactement ce
que vous demandez, vous savez peut-être à
peu près  que vous savez que c'est dans cette zone
et que vous voulez peut-être aller à la fête d'anniversaire de quelqu'un,
mais vous ne connaissez certainement pas
l'adresse, ce n'est pas quelque chose dont
vous vous souviendriez et la plupart des assistants d'
aujourd'hui échoueraient fondamentalement
comprendrait que vous voulez un uber mais
ensuite ils ne pouvaient pas trouver d'adresse et
donc ils renverraient une réponse maladroite en
disant hey je suis désolé je ne comprends pas vraiment
ce que vous vouliez dire et à ce
moment-là vous abandonnez probablement  c'est vrai,
mais vraiment si vous lui donnez accès à
chaque élément de données sur votre
vie s'il a ce graphique de connaissances sous-jacent
qui représente des informations comme
vous le feriez, vous êtes en mesure de déterminer que
Rand est un contact qu'il y a une
fête d'anniversaire et les événements  qui sont
liés à cette personne et que parce que
vous avez besoin d'une adresse, vous pouvez l'extraire
de l'événement et l'envoyer à boogie
uber sans ce graphe de connaissances sous-jacent
qui représente vraiment la
couche mémoire de votre assistant artificiel, il
serait impossible de comprendre des
choses simples qui  un humain pourrait très facilement faire
pour vous, vous pouvez également aller plus loin,
vous pouvez commencer à réfléchir à la façon dont cela
peut être intégré avec d'autres appareils
que vous utilisez si vous souhaitez désactiver le
lumières si votre assistant a accès à
tout ce qu'il sait que vous êtes actuellement à la
maison, il sait que les lumières à proximité
sont allumées et c'est donc ce que
veut réellement éteindre c'est
particulièrement important car dès
que votre assistant n'est pas capable de
gérer les appareils pour vous il peut également
commencer à apprendre comment vous les utilisez il peut
commencer à apprendre à quelle heure vous rentrez
chez vous pour vous assurer que vous ne
chauffez pas votre maison pour rien il peut
s'assurer qu'il peut apprendre que lorsque vous les
regardez vous filmer  comme les lumières à un certain
niveau, cela peut être appris lorsque vous avez un
dîner avec des amis, vous aimez ce
type de musique et cela pourrait commencer à
automatiser tout cela et donc vous voyez
quand nous parlons de faire
disparaître la technologie en arrière-plan, il doit
passez par cette phase d'enseignement à votre
assistant du genre de choses que vous voulez
qu'il fasse de sorte que dans tous les cas, vous n'ayez plus à
toucher les appareils, il y a cependant un gros
problème qui est de pouvoir
faire des choses  en dehors d'un seul
appareil, vous ne parlez donc plus d'un
smartphone mais de tous ces
appareils connectés autour de vous, comment
garantissez-vous toujours la confidentialité car, par
définition, n'est plus dans un seul appareil,
vous devez faire des choses dans les nuages, il
s'avère  qu'il y a un nouveau type de
cryptographie qui arrive en
ce moment donc c'est
incroyable honnêtement comme je
code depuis que j'ai 10 ans et je
n'ai pas été autant enthousiasmé par une nouvelle technologie
que celle-ci  un dans très très
longtemps alors supportez-moi une seconde
cela s'appelle le cryptage homomorphe cela
semble extrêmement compliqué car
c'est mais conceptuellement c'est très simple l'
idée est que vous pouvez directement exécuter vos
algorithmes sur les données cryptées alors
disons que vous prenez  cet emplacement sur votre
téléphone intelligent au lieu d'envoyer l'
emplacement réel au serveur, ce que vous
faites, c'est que vous cryptez l'emplacement, envoyez-
le au cloud afin que le cloud n'ait
pas la clé qu'il n'a aucun moyen de savoir  ing
où vous êtes, il vient de recevoir un
nombre aléatoire, mais la façon dont il est
crypté préserve en fait la
propriété mathématique afin que vous puissiez faire des
multiplications d'additions, ce qui signifie que vous pouvez
réellement exécuter n'importe quel type d'
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle compliqués sur
les données cryptées elles-mêmes, vous produisez un
résultat qui  vous ne comprenez toujours pas
vous n'avez pas la clé c'est comme
opérer à l'intérieur d'une boîte noire vous ne savez pas
ce que vous touchez ici renvoyez-le
au smartphone qui peut ensuite le
déchiffrer et interpréter les
résultats c'est tellement révolutionnaire  type de
technologie qui signifie que
chaque calcul, chaque service
qui existe aujourd'hui sur cette planète pourrait
potentiellement être effectué sans jamais avoir besoin que
vous envoyiez vos données au fournisseur,
chaque entreprise pourrait être rentable, offrir des
services très gourmands en données
sans aucun risque  à la
vie privée et donc oh c'est vraiment
important, vous voyez parce que depuis que je
suis enfant, tout le monde a été promis  ng un
avenir qui ressemble à un film de science-fiction
quelque chose de très technologiquement
oppressant avec de grands
bâtiments métalliques partout une énorme publicité
sur la place et la police vous regarde
et lettre chaque mouvement que vous connaissez la société
essentiellement où vous arrivez à un point de
Oh à  une censure si extrême que
tout le monde devient exactement la même
personne, mais quand vous parlez aux gens quand
vous parlez juste aux gens, vous
réalisez que ce qu'ils veulent, c'est vraiment
quelque chose comme ça, tout le monde
veut être sur une plage, vous savez que les gens
aiment la tranquillité  ils aiment se
déconnecter ils n'aiment pas la technologie la
technologie n'a qu'un seul but
est d'aider les gens à avoir une vie meilleure et
donc ce que je crois très fermement aujourd'hui, c'est
que si nous voulons vivre dans un avenir
où l'intelligence artificielle peut nous
débarrasser de  technologie dont nous aurons besoin pour le
faire d'une manière qui garantit également notre
vie privée parce que la différence entre
vivre dans leur monde où nous sommes
fondamentalement tous  y esclaves de cette technologie et de
ces intelligences artificielles dans un
monde où nous avons la liberté de faire
tout ce qui nous tient à cœur sera notre
capacité à le faire merci